[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
how's it going
two weeks of original comedy specials
what are they talking about
i can't remember all recorded live
and netflix is a joke the festival now
we gotta pay for this twice
best of the fast
today is monday august 1st and netflix
is entering the compilation game baby
coming into our arena stepping on our
toes on our turf making best of moments
for the netflix is a joke comedy
festival and look you know me i
appreciate a good compilation i love a
good best of funniest moments as much as
the next guy probably more than the next
guy but netflix stinks at it and if you
watch this video i'll tell you why but
first let me welcome you back to the
joke world comedy update every single
monday bring you the comedy news that
you need to know from your favorite
comedians your favorite podcasts new
specials new shows if a comedian gets
assaulted on stage we're covering it all
for you every single monday so please
consider subscribing to joke world right
now downloading this episode on spotify
and turning on those post notifications
to support the channel so this was the
best of netflix as a joke festival which
took place in may and then ever since
then they've been releasing these uh
specials they call them basically once a
week a lot of our news updates in the
past have been about these and this is
just the best of those moments so they
had the bill burr friends who kill they
had the hall of fame thing that they did
last week they had the snoop dogg and
friends special the p davidson and
friend special then they had a david
letterman my next guest segment and this
was an hour long of like all the
funniest best bits best stand-up moments
from all of those specials combined into
one thing obviously if you're watching
this video you know how compilations
work but this was one just from that
festival now we've discussed this
festival a lot on the comedy news update
i've honestly thought it was a little
lazy for them to charge money for people
to attend this festival then record
everything in one take and release it
out all year long but then i would start
to think oh you know what that is
actually kind of cool i guess you know
they're making the most of
the opportunities that they have to have
all these great comics working in this
one festival and then you know releasing
more comedy on netflix there's nothing
wrong with that i thought it was a
little lazy at first but the more i
thought about it
the more i appreciate what they're doing
this best of moments though is is kind
of trash honestly it's um
there's some good i wrote down some time
stamps so it starts off with bill burr
him doing some stand up at the bill burn
friends uh show which we did a whole
video discussing that then the next
watchable moment is when samurail is on
at seven minutes and 30 seconds so i'd
watch the billboard then skip right to 7
30. and then after that go to 18 20
which is when brian robinson's on stage
and then it's just slow as molasses
until christina p gets up at 46 10.
in between there's just stuff that you
don't i don't i don't even know
you don't need to see
or i don't know whatever do whatever you
want but those were the funny parts so
if you're watching it and you're like
this sucks go to those time stamps and
uh you should be good netflix also
released a real special this week from
whitney cummings titled jokes that's
what's called whitney cummings jokes i
like the name simple right to the point
this is what netflix has to say about it
whitney gets personal about sex injuries
and dating younger men spills on her
online photo leak and is nostalgic about
life before social media
so all pretty mainstream you know
generic topics it was a fine special i
watched it you know it had its moments
both ways it had some good and bad
moments i'm not like a whitney hater i
feel like a lot of people are very
anti-whitney on the internet i'm not a
fan and i'm not a anti-whitney i am just
i know nothing about her but this was
fine i mean
i will have a few takeaways one is like
there are more applause breaks i think
than like big laughter breaks um which i
don't necessarily think is a great thing
if you're making people laugh at you
know the points that you're saying more
than laughing at your jokes
seems more of kind of like a speech but
whatever the other thing i'll say about
the special versus whitney in general is
like i enjoyed watching her i think more
on podcast this week because she went on
god knows how many podcasts this week i
thought it was more
entertaining and uh comical to see her
on the pods than in this special my
screen just went out for the first time
in a while that's pretty funny um but
not quite as funny as whitney's special
or it's about the same funniness i would
say so go check that out if you want
we're here with the one and only whitney
cummings
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you uh whitney's got a specialist
out right now netflix we're going to
check it out right now no actually
andrew just bought it okay
you bought the special you bought it
back from purpose
you want to get one free exactly what
happened you get whitney special if you
buy my special you also get winnie
special if you just log into netflix and
watch that [ __ ] uh i'm so stoked that
you're here thank you so much for coming
i love you you're amazing i love you so
much and for those of you that think i'm
the transport star that was on
episodes ago i'm not damn it i'm not
uh i think it's sexy oh stop whitney
but i feel like you didn't paint the one
that would go into a [ __ ]
because he doesn't need that
that's
the guest list is where we go through
some of the main podcasts from last week
to make sure that you'll miss any
appearances by some of your favorite
comedians on your favorite shows so to
start off your mom's house did not have
a guest two bears one cave was good old
burton tom tom and bert the joe rogan
experience had on whitney cummings joey
diaz was on the honeydew last week this
past weekend with theovan did not have a
guest whitney cummings was also on tiger
belly with bobby lee and kalila bobby
comes home and he has a picture next to
a guy who's towering over him and he
goes who's this kalila who did i take a
picture with and it's a blake griffin
who is
great guy so funny it's so funny yeah
yeah no but like did stand up at
montreal and was hilarious yeah like
he's legitimately i just with blake
griffin though because he was he was
he's always around
i don't care i i know that he'll crush
me but i'm just saying that
he'll destroy me but i just i just never
got a sense that he liked me like like
because i see him with him with other
comics and ass playing why did you take
a picture with him and who did you think
he was
stevie okay
boom boom call back what no i thought
what's up what's up ac no i thought he
was um
well just a tall comedian from new york
it's all like as if tall men have to
become comedians i'm just no you know
because there's there's ones like gary
goldman they're tall there's one
gary goldman yeah and he's
uh his whole thing is i can't stop
taking antidepressants
whiskey ginger had on andrew schultz and
bad friends had on will sasso hey it's
really good to be here will sasso and
chad culture for the dudesy podcast at
dudesy podca on all your socials of
course check us out on youtube spotify
apple itunes spotify on tuesday wherever
you get your podcast hey i'm sitting
across from a couple of really good
friends here podcast world
yeah i know
there's nothing funnier than like being
meta and making fun of a thing you do
you guys
hey everybody yeah oh what am i a
podcast guy yeah yeah you know what
literally we already started doing we're
pop i like when people we make on
podcasts are good
it's the thing we do right
now
i'm sitting over here you're sitting
over there that color this wall that
color that wall
and logo looks like us kind of doesn't
kind of doesn't have a ram or a ramble
you put the chopper thing into the glass
chris rock yep he's good that is that
was good
i thought it was denzela first yeah yeah
but that's definitely chris rock let me
hear it do another christmas i have to
be a black
put the dragon just to drink
nancy pelosi nancy pelosi is that nancy
pelosi
yeah yeah specials last week we had
whitney cummings and jokes that we
already talked about go check that one
out if it interests you and then a few
weeks ago paul versi came out with
natural admissions that's also on
netflix we have not talked about that
one yet but it's pretty funny go check
that one out those are two that you know
if you're looking to get into a special
those are kind of new other than that
this has been another episode of the
joke world comedy update every single
monday bring you the comedy news so
please again subscribe and like and you
know comment for the algorithm do all
the cool youtube stuff that you know you
would want done on your channel
thank you for watching though i don't
know how to end these dude just you know
[ __ ]
thanks
[Music]
you